Good morning,
everybody.
Morning, morning, morning.
Hello, hello, everyone.
Today, we're going to be playing Nothing to Declare, which
is apparently a TSA simulator.
Oh, I love the fact that we can beat TSA for the day.
Finally, my dream come true.
Inconveniencing airport travelers.
Finally, the day I've been waiting for, I can finally make
them late for their flight.
Oh, my dream job.
And also, not getting paid for it, too.
Finally, I could be on the other side.
Welcome to, okay, I was going to, okay, I didn't realize,
because I was going to be like, call it being like super
clever.
I'd be like, ha, the DSA, the Dokeybird Security
Association.
And then I saw someone chat and was like, you could tell
Doki Braid is not American because she called herself the
DSA.
And I was just like, what's wrong with that?
What's the data system and analysis?
Like, I was just like, what's the DSA?
And then I was just like, data system analysis?
Like, what is it?
And I looked up DSA and I was like, oh, the Democratic
Socialist of America.
ah
yeah the digital service act I was just like what does that
guy do with being America being American I was so confused I
was like ah I see
the bong thank you for the super chat thank you thank you if
there's nothing to glare then there's no point to go to
Sinclair for an acclare thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you wow Tokia Wow.
I can't believe you went political.
I, guys, I'm the dokey.
I'm the dokey at bird and security administration.
Guys, that's nothing to do with socialism.
I just want to make sure you don't bring a bottle of water
to the airport.
That's it.
I'm just trying to make sure you don't bring a dangerous
item in here, through the airport, like a fucking Like a
fucking scissor.
You know how dangerous that is?
To have scissors?
You can hurt yourself.
Alright, let's play Nothing to Declare.
Um, anyway, so Dad's here, but also not here.
I have him on a Zoom call to help me.
Uh, to put...
To help me sniff, uh, sniff stuff out.
Um...
Wait, let me...
Let's see, but, but, but, but, but, but.
Alright, I don't know sound, guys.
here.
He's like Schrodinger's dad.
He's here, but he's not here at the same time.
He's going to be doing a really good job helping me sniff
out the drugs.
All right, let's see.
I see you're carrying a dog with you.
We'll have to ask you to send him to the dog's gate.
Check him for bombs this time.
Now he's on the other side.
Now he's going to check if your dogs have bombs.
All right, let me see.
guy let me know how it sounds like um at the moment you can
um is that large tube of toothpaste permanent bad exactly
just here to make sure you don't bring that toothpaste over
here there might be a bomb inside it all right never seen a
weiner dog do tsa hey he's a very special he's a very
special dog all right he's a prodigy they let him in an
exception because of how good he is at his job.
Lolly, thank you, thank you, thank you.
I have a suggestion for a shitpost, Songkart.
We are number one, the meme song from Lay's Town.
But it's you sing of other dokees from the dokevers.
That's a good one.
Thank you, the super chat, thank you, thank you.
That's a good shitpost.
All right, let's see.
All right, here are the settings.
Sound guy.
Speech, ADHD, autism filter.
Let's just like, what?
is an autism filter i have never seen that before
what i mean i guess that's good it's less repeating sound
effects and no but i've never seen a game have an autism
filter that's wow
how bad is the how bad is like the sound effects on Noah
lives if there's an autism filter.
Oh, I'm worried now.
We need the autism filter.
Okay, let's go.
Holiday season, a typical expect gradual increase in
passenger.
Take your time and enjoy the couch casting of a super chat.
Thank you.
The five hour, the dinner is like, why is, why does it take
so long at the T.
sorry now your TSA agent is on cozy mode right now next
scene thank you for the super chat thank you thank you we're
so sorry the agent is on cozy mode right now so so you gotta
wait five hours till your flight till you get fast the TSA
oh so the usual yes we're always on the cozy we're always on
the cozy level all right let's check this game out I thought
it was pretty cool just because Because, like, I've never
really seen games that...
Oh, it's like Paper Please, but the TSA.
I like how, like, the modern-day American version of the
Paper Please Communist Make-Believe Country is the TSA.
That's crazy.
That's the modern-day American version of this.
Not right.
It was made for me.
American version.
Oh my god.
I don't know why my own stream played on my phone.
I freaked out.
I was like, who was that?
And I was like, that's me, but on my phone.
It like played on my speakers for something.
The Doki jump scare.
Thanks.
Thanks three seconds behind Doki.
Okay.
Welcome to the checkpoint, rookie.
Let's run, run together.
All right.
Also, today's gonna be a short stream only because I have a
lot of stuff to do in between my streams today There is
potential where I might be late for armor core because I
have to touch grass and buy some stuff for my vacation So I
just want to let you guys know that right now There is a
potential where I might be late for armor core just because
I have to I have to touch grass in between my streams And do
some a little bit of shop last-minute shopping and stuff All
right, I need to buy shoes basically because I haven't
bought new shoes in like three plus years and I'm gonna need
new shoes well my sneakers are like two years old but like I
need like I okay so like when I had to like do like an
emergency move and everything you know I could only bring
like what I could like I could only move like it was like I
basically had to pack everything like within a couple of
hours before like I moved out and everything um and so so
shoes was sort of my last priority so I legitimately just
like brought two pairs of shoes uh and I never bought new
shoes after I the only time I bought new shoes was sneakers
so um so I was just like all right these will go fine I have
sandals and sneakers and my sandals are sort of falling
apart now uh and so I'm So I'm gonna have to, I have to buy
new shoes for my vacation.
I used to have a big collection of shoes, but like I said, I
had to like move really quickly.
So I was just like, and then like, and then I just had only
two pairs.
I only brought two pairs of shoes.
And at that point, my, and by the time, like my sneakers had
like one year left.
And then, um, and then like I bought new sneakers, but even
then my sneakers are sort of falling apart now.
So I might have to buy new sneakers soon-ish not now because
I still can like I still have uses of it It's like it's not
falling apart yet, but like it's getting there
and and so um so but I definitely need new sandals new
sandals are fucked up like my old sandals at the moment are
sort of a little bit fucked up so that's why I have to uh,
I'm gonna have to go buy new shoes and other things as well
uh them yeah they have not lived their usefulness yet uh so
so yeah we're gonna we're gonna i'll be moving around a lot
after this stream before my other stream um that's why
today's gonna be a little bit shorter i won't be doing a
five hour stream like last time this is your desk inspect
decide stamp start by opening my passport oh my god this is
actually just paper please that's you that's not you check
the photo first compare it with me not even close that's
yeah I was gonna say that's there's no way that's you unless
you got like a bit of you lost weight chain started wearing
contact started wearing colored contacts dyed your hair and
started shaving a little bit more and also that your name is
security officer i guess i don't know maybe he really loves
his job at the tsa you don't know that you can't judge
someone by their name maybe he just really loves the tsa
that he changed his he officially changed his name to to
commemorate his his passion for the job uh nsc uh thank you
for the five gift dishes thank you thank you open the report
board all right hello use reject reasons to oh my god this
is i'm sorry but this is actually uh it's called a glow up
toky tap papa oh like change your entire identity maybe it's
like he's on he's actually on the witness protection uh
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Name, mismatch, photo mismatch.
I don't know about age.
I won't say...
Do I check the age?
Like, I can't tell.
Close the board and open the passport again.
Alright.
Use the reject stamp.
Alright, where's the reject stamp?
Oh, there it is.
Oh my god, wait, this...
And everything back.
Okay.
There you go.
That's 13.
Check, report, stamp, return.
And send him to jail.
Passports, please.
All right.
My name is Victor.
Oh, hey, wait a minute.
Well, his name is Victor.
Photo mismatch.
Do you have any question?
How old are you?
42?
How long will you stay?
What is the purpose?
Wait.
Madrid what is your name all right so you definitely don't
look like this guy so I'm gonna send you off now my name is
Calvin Reed bro what the fuck I don't even name okay name
how old are you 23 yeah get out of here select a reject
reason I did hello
Uh...
Oh, okay.
Name.
Get out of here.
Get your ass out of here.
In fact, security!
That guy has a bomb!
He has a different- his name is different.
He has a bomb.
Most likely.
Why else would you tell me the wrong name?
I don't understand.
Alright.
Why else?
That's the only reason you would tell me the wrong name.
I don't see any other reason.
Oh shit, I could call a security.
When will I need to call a security?
All right.
Let's see.
What is your name?
How old are you?
You're 40.
One to two weeks.
Tourism.
Sydney.
That doesn't look like tourism clothes.
But you know what?
That's not my job to care.
jobs and wherever you're heading.
inspection.
Look at that.
Perf.
I'm doing my job.
He's dressed to impress.
Alright.
End of the day.
Nice.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Do I just leave?
Bye.
More than five unbaved pages.
bills.
All right, pay my electricity bills.
That's fine by me.
Oh, yeah, I forgot.
Music could come.
Oh, wait, I did do it.
Sound, guys.
The music better now?
Okay, start the day.
When do I start scanning stuff?
From today on, passengers need a board.
Oh, my God.
We were not letting passengers through with a boarding pass.
What are we doing?
Okay, we can tell these are one of those airports that got
funding cut.
We We're trying to be efficient.
We're just going to assume that everybody...
Oh, yeah, definitely.
I just realized we are definitely one of the...
We're one of the smaller airports at, like, a city with a
hundred people.
So, I get it.
Only, like, technically only two airlines.
Only two airlines come to our airlines.
airport.
Also bring up sound effects more.
Alright, I'll bring up sound effects more.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, the passenger...
Also, this music feels like I'm in the airport right now.
The passenger details should... When are the... When are
they gonna start bringing toothpaste, guys?
So I can shock him.
Check the flight date and route.
These are the baggage limit.
You'll need them later.
What do you mean later?
Like, we're out of, we've been out of order for 20 years.
Yeah, that used to be ran by Spirit Airlines.
Yeah, our, our, our airline, the only airlines that come to
our airport is Spirit Airlines
and private jets, because they got a refuel.
And now that Spirit Airlines went bankrupt, we're sort of
like, we, we're sort of like in a bit of a trouble right now
um it's the fancy option at this airport nsd you think it
was super chat thank you thank you name passport number
details make sure they line up now check the flight date
what date is it today oh january it's expired that's a
violation oh yeah it is okay how do i progress from okay all
right open the report board okay Select expired.
Close the board.
Bam!
Alright.
Take your fucking expired airport boarding pass.
The Aversus Spirit went bankrupt.
We've sort of been trying to look for private investors in
our airport.
My name is Reed Sullivan.
Alright, Reed Sullivan.
Let's see.
I'm grabbing my board right now.
now how okay how old are you 25 all right sounds good how
long you're gonna say four to seven days what is your
purpose all right tourism that sounds good where are you
traveling to toronto all right you know what everything
checks out let's go go do your go go toronto all right let's
see all right how's your day my name is leon Carter.
Liam Carter.
He's bald.
Get him!
Alright, Liam.
Let's see.
Jan.
Oh!
Bam!
I don't even need to expire boarding pass.
Try to fly past the date.
Bro, you're not... Bro, even if it was EU time, you would
expire two days.
Alright, Lucas Bennett.
Alright.
Let's see.
January 2nd.
Alright, you seem to know your age which is good that means
you've done your homework all right what all right we're
traveling to london study how are you staying for for four
weeks what the fuck are you studying i mean i don't judge
i'm just a underpaid government worker who cares go go do
your thing as long as you're not bringing toothpaste well to
be fair right now they can bring as many toothpaste as they
won like apparently in in this airport we don't care uh and
ben and haze and all right i don't even need a here i don't
even need a look all right nice perfect inspection as always
i'm good at my job all right here you go how dare you all
right i'm here to end my day goodbye more than mobile plan
payment all right i mean i have to be on my phone in between
in between tsa oh wait i have my retirement oh wait i i have
a retirement plan why wasn't this told to me you what do you
mean would i get a gift box i'm gonna deposit that a hundred
thousand grand they got made of money i'm work for the tsa
it's not game it's tsa simple mind i think it was super
chatting of course they wouldn't tell me about my retirement
plan so i can work here forever and i and don't worry it's
my i love my job so it's okay um chase hunter yeah uh name
mismatch all right buddy you forgot your
documents all right sebastian cole january 3rd i'm grabbing
my inspection board we're traveling to london visiting
family all right that sounds right undecided well you do
have five years um usually it's not good to tell me you're
undecided but we're we're like i haven't had my paycheck in
seven months so like that's not my priority i usually you're
supposed to tell me how long you're staying so you're not
illegally staying in another country uh should i take my
shoes up buddy we don't even have a working machine our our
drug checking dog is sleeping you think i care right now i
my name is willa coles Oh, January 2nd, reject.
Expired boarding pass.
Let's go.
Move along, ma'am.
Move along.
This is the fastest the TSA has ever worked, by the way.
Madison Pierce.
I think we actually do only have one airline here at this
airport.
All right.
Madison Pierce.
We're traveling to London.
Medical.
47 days.
24.
Oh, you think our healthcare is not good enough for you?
I mean, hey.
It's not it's your fault for not paying for private health
care All right, that is perfect perfect perfect nice end of
the day Hey, they use super chat that you thank you so many
people pay try to fly with live lobsters that certain
airports have came that specifically Train to sniff them out
not drugs bombs just lobsters dad What's wrong with
lobsters?
There's a lost and found box too?
Wait, waiting area.
How do I leave?
How do I... How do I...
What's this?
Oh, I would like to purchase the... Oh, my god.
It's a blind box.
There's the duty-free shop.
Alright.
Gotta fill my pet food.
Oh, yeah.
Dad, of course.
I remember to refill your food.
Alright.
let's see oh nice work so far rookie time to scan the
passenger oh my god we finally fixed it damn i know we've
been having a lot of passengers coming through with knives
lately um i might have been our fault but i have a lot of
like uh stab stabbing cases lately in this airport This is
the avian secure pad Moving over Finally Oh my god We've
been waiting for this for five years We finally fixed the
scanners guys Still haven't had my paycheck though Alright
Moving over Alright What the fuck is that a bomb?
Just Red me out Red, oh, red V's down.
We're, guys, don't worry.
Our airport's really safe, guys.
Do not worry.
We only have 10 cases a day, which drops from 30.
So we gotta, you know, we gotta take what we can get.
What are you?
Illegal?
Yeah, I would think so.
Yeah, that, that seems pretty illegal.
them by the way but what if the bomb is oh whoa wowie but
what if the bomb's blue they're just yeah they're just
really fancy candles all right damn none of your bones are
connected all right give me a sec just giving you some
radiation to the brain nothing bad is gonna happen from that
if you get cancer in two to three years it is unrelated it
is very much unrelated oh i'm checking i just gotta stab
this for you get out of here uh expired boarding pass there
all right sounds good for him all right old man it's okay
you're older already so i can I'm legally allowed.
Oh, whoa.
What's this?
Is that a knife?
Excuse me, Grandpa.
All right.
Uh.
Okay.
Lucas E.
Bennett.
Okay.
All right.
Um.
We might need to...
We might...
Why can't I call security?
It's because he's old.
I'm just...
It's not even letting me call ways because he's legal item
filed.
Um...
Grandpa, grandpa...
Just...
We gotta go.
Grandpa, lock him up.
He still thinks he's in the war right now.
out oh my god what is this what is this an olden bracelet
the fuck is that what is this are you not is he not allowed
to bring a bracelet i don't even what's wrong with it i've
been to an air strip in the middle of the cornfield that has
better standards than this airport this must be lax Doug,
thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
His name is Kai Turner.
He's going to Rome.
Study.
One to two.
Why are you studying for one to two weeks?
I don't understand.
All right.
Well, you're allowed to go.
Nope.
Minus $50.
Return the item.
Oh, man.
We seem to have lost your item, man.
how care oh is that pub g why you carry pub g in your
fucking stomach uh why is it taped to your stomach all right
you know pub g has guns in them i have to confiscate that
game uh return the slab all right what's your name again my
name is lucy bennett we're traveling to berlin conference
one to three days 20 all right you see seem good to go I
I've actually realized I've stopped looking at photos all
right here's your here's your pub G ma'am she's trying to
smuggle pub G I oh a correct inspection oh name mismatch I
oh my God even realized I have to like I I don't know like I
see it you know the fact that like he no issues found yeah I
get to keep the item how am I supposed to like he had a
fucking knife Should I care about his name being wrong?
Like,
Why does she have a physical copy?
The game is free.
What level am I on?
I assume January 4th is like, Jesus, I've always had bills
to pay.
All right, start the day.
Am I learning anything new?
No, all right.
My name is...
All right, what's this?
Okay, is that an illegal item?
Oh, is that...
considered illegal it's a wrench she has a wrench get her
okay i just need to know like please take your glasses off
too if you're not going to take your glasses off i will call
security one to two weeks uh well i mean uh was it red
though i don't know but there's a big triangle on it I'm
gonna...
Illegal item found.
She has a wrench!
Security!
Oh, I don't think it was illegal.
I just realized it actually might not have been illegal
because I...
I can't do anything with this wrench.
Oops.
Uh...
Oh...
Oh, oh,
um, my, um, the person that was shadowing did not teach me
this, guys.
Um, all I'm going to say is my mentor, the person who was
supposed to teach me, didn't teach me that wrenches were, in
fact, not illegal.
blame me can you really blame me oh my god she has okay i
should just not like having spoiled fish is technically not
illegal but like morally wise i should just like kick you
out just for the fact that you brought spoiled fish like i
mentally i don't think you are fit to fly and you were going
to go to tokyo Tokyo does not need you ma'am like I have all
I'm saying is that um I feel like morally wise I should not
let you on this plane uh organic is that considered organic
I don't know is yeah it's a bio weapon Welcome to tomato
farm.
Welcome.
It's in general waste or organic.
It has an apple on it.
There's general waste too.
I don't know.
All right.
Okay, nice.
It's considered.
All right, ma'am.
You're free to go.
Does it actually look that edible?
All right, what's this?
Oh, that's, that, oh, oh, that might be bad.
I mean, read.
Can I, am I also like, what's all, what's that other word
for you?
Hard to, people who can't read, like, it's hard to make it
hard to read.
Uh, all right.
Well, I'm going to have to take you out of the airport.
Not on a date.
You, you're literally carrying acid.
I'm scared of you.
uh yeah dyslexic am i also dyslexic why can't i like type
her name out properly okay she has an illegal item but i'm
gonna double check if she's lying about her age too uh oh
visiting family oh my god to toronto all right well her only
crime is that she um brought acid so only crime guys Just
the only thing wrong about her name is Damien.
What do you have, Claire?
Mysterious Mushrooms.
Alright.
Oh, also I guess he might be like lying about his age
question mark.
Alright, what does my guidebook say about Owing?
Okay, Owing Mitchell.
How old are you?
Damn.
All right.
Years have been rough.
Have you been to Turkey recently?
Well, he's going to Dubai.
So have you been to Turkey as well?
Just so, you know, just wondering.
Oh, yeah.
Security.
All right.
Here we are.
Wrong inspection.
Okay.
That was, like, an accident.
Correct name mismatch.
Oh, I forgot about the name.
That's fine.
This did pretty well.
Yeah.
And day.
Alright, water bill.
Alright.
Next day.
I should have this now.
Oh my god, the funding came in!
From today on every bag goes through the x-ray first.
This machine shows you what's inside.
Start to convey your belt all right oh my god finally oh my
god the funding has come through guys we got private
investor at the airport what the fuck is that okay
sunglasses all blue this one's clear move it to desk and
check the tag all right
all right carry on give it back to me oh shit i'm gonna look
inside oh who is that an apple watch oh is this an apple why
let's try another okay all right whoops all right oh that's
a yellow open up take the yellow item all right what's in
there oh oh basil oh someone's gonna be cooking Drop in the
trash.
Oh, now you teach me this.
Oh, oh, you know, maybe I wouldn't have arrested that poor
lady if I knew I could just throw away a wrench.
You won't be needing that.
Okay, oh, now.
Now they tell me about this.
Oh, yeah, okay.
After I arrested the lady for bringing a wrench to the
airport.
Put it back on the belt.
Alright.
all right it's like a little sushi belt
carry on checking bag stays on the belt all right that seems
like easy enough all right i think i'm ready for this i'm
i'm ready the dsa is ready to move on to the next customer
you know it could go a lot faster you know if uh if yo chase
hunter Why do you look like you got me late?
I am gay.
J-Red, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Love the playful bird.
Give me the super chat, thank you.
What is your name again?
Alright, okay.
There's several things wrong here.
So, expired boarding pass and photo mismatch.
And then let's see if you have any drugs on you, sir.
Oh, and you're carrying salt?
Oh.
Um.
That's bad.
Here you go.
Good.
Illegal.
Illegal salt.
Straight into the gulag.
My name is Ella Foster.
Okay.
That seems like the right date.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I didn't even realize.
oh all right that's all right carry on wait a wait a minute
wait a minute you're allowed oh what's that okay let me see
oh yeah cookbook to do you know a yellow hard hat what's
this make sure this is correct jan rdi airport b22a that
seems correct all right That looks good to go.
All right, what's this, though?
What got scanned?
The ink stand and the tie.
All right, that...
All right, let me check Ella Foster to New York to Rome.
Wait, we're in New York City?
We're just like really...
I just realized we're just like really, really small airport
on the outskirts of New York City.
I just realized where we are at.
Look, there's like several airports in New York, and we're
one of them.
Ella Foster, Rome, how long?
We stay undecided.
27.
All right.
Everything seems to look good.
Wait until all the baggage is cleared.
Oh, yeah.
Here you go.
I forgot to give it back there.
Would you just put that through the chat?
package and just hope that everything stays there all right
new york toronto yeah let's hope that open no cover opening
package stays safe all right this looks like a carry-on
let's see c228 luna turner are you luna turner you are luna
turner all right let me make sure you don't have any drugs
on you okay just some headphones on your leg all right i
should obviously detain you for putting it on your leg uh
all right what's your how old are how long will you be
staying one to two weeks what's the purpose transit how old
are 18 all right everything looks good to go luna turner
yeah weird spot but okay i can't rest you for being fucking
weirdo Alistair Pendleton.
Ignore the ticking.
It's time.
It's a time calibrator.
Not a contraband.
I missed a critical 1893 tea party destroying the timeline.
I mean I guess.
I mean $200 is $200.
You know what?
Alright, let me see uh oh i'll take this all right 200 is a
tour he doesn't seem like he's dressed as you know someone
that's trying to bomb the plane so you know what i'll give
it a pass all right let's see here you go oh it's a check-in
bag all right let me all right what about your other stuff
though My name is Alistair Pendleton.
Like, his last name is...
Oh, he's going to Tokyo, too.
Yeah, that seems like something a guy who's going to Tokyo
gonna do.
You know what?
Alistair, go have fun.
Alright, let me scan him real quick.
Yeah, see?
It's not carrying anything illegal.
Oh, wait.
Everything's fine.
Oh, shit.
$200 runies.
Let's go.
All right, correct inspection.
Perfect.
And bribe taken.
Yay.
He's just a weep.
Is that a crime?
Is it a crime to be a weep?
Just your ordinary time traveler.
Nighting out with some friends.
Let's go.
It's not a crime to be a weep.
Bavagen saw through a walk through mail detector.
It checks passengers automatically.
Oh, thank God.
I'm carrying metal training sample.
Watch the gate.
Red flash.
Warning chime.
It found something legal.
You can't tell you where I can use a body x-ray.
Pick it up on the scanner.
What about the drugs, though?
I don't think...
What is that?
A rhino horn?
Oh.
Okay.
Yep.
Security.
Alarm scan report.
all right all
right here we go oh wait oh i forgot to take the money i
just left it there at work i'm glad nobody took it thank god
all right madison pierce you have one luggage and one care
oh wait you have something legal on you what's that the fuck
what um okay madison Man, they get them young these days.
Uh-huh.
Madison Pierce.
Boop.
All right.
Are you doing anything else illegal?
Just wondering.
I'm fucking Mercury.
You're 19.
Madison Pierce.
One or two weeks.
Medical.
I guess.
All right.
Well, I mean, 1985.
Alright.
8213A?
I mean, this looks...
Alright.
I mean...
Oh, alright.
And she's...
Okay.
Quarter life.
That's good.
Uh, well, I'm just gonna have to sap that.
Say, illegal item.
And then call security.
and i do be crazy they do get them young wait okay connor
walsh all right connor let's see how many items are bringing
three baggage what the fuck are you doing in kaira all right
b2 19b one of your check-in baggages your rubrics cube that
seems fine
That doesn't look like a check.
Okay, that is a checking bag.
Okay, never mind.
Goggles, camera.
Oh, she is touring, touring.
All right.
What about here?
Is it not gonna scan it?
How am I supposed to know if it's okay?
How am I?
It's not blue.
Oh, it's all blue.
All right.
Okay, varsity.
Bro, you gotta be a more efficient packer.
I can't, I'm, I'm, I can't, I, I mean, I'm not gonna judge
you.
I'm not paid enough to judge you.
you, but this is not efficient at all.
Alright, 24.
Everything seems right.
You look like the photo and everything.
I'll put your baggage through this.
Yeah, he's actually...
I will say, you are not a very efficient packer.
Two shirts and a video game in one luggage, guys.
He has three check-in.
Oh, what's this?
Like, it's just plants all right is it i mean it is just
parsley and he's oh but what's this though huh what's wait i
think that's just mushrooms i all right all right buddy just
plants you touched their belongings and deal is off.
I'm, all I'm saying is, might be more than just plants,
buddy.
Herbie Green.
Oh, yeah, sound guys.
Everything good now for sound?
Okay, Herbie Green.
Ooh.
And your name is quite more than just plants.
Alright.
Let's see.
The item found.
What else?
My name is be green i mean everything else is good yeah just
i can't i mean guess you can use it in madrid if you're
going to cook and everything but still it's still bro there
was a mysterious mushroom in here all right get out get out
yeah go to the other airport you want brain those mysterious
mushrooms on board my name is hudson 2 29 he looks like him
all right what is that what is this over here oh oh you're
trying to bring a hair conditioner you're trying to bring a
bomb to my plane oh my god it took so long for that to scan
all right what's this trading card oh you were trying to
make a bomb, weren't you?
Yeah, you think I didn't know?
Trying to make a bomb with a hair conditioner and a room
spray?
Alright, let's see.
What else is it?
Hudson Clark.
29.
Oh, wait.
You're not even allowed to be here.
Okay, wait.
Expired boarding pass.
Everything else looks good just not this though i assume
it's tech and meta right am i not allowed to dispose this is
this can am i supposed to where's this supposed oh liquids
okay oh yeah that's a liquid right yeah that's a liquid all
right rejected wait until the baggage cleared i rejected him
We're going to wait until the baggage goes to the TSA.
All right, next customer, please.
Perfect inspection.
I'm so good at my job.
When does...
Oh, wait.
Lost and found.
Day 12?
Sorry, guys.
If you lost something here, good luck.
Repair kit reduces...
Increases a dog detection.
accuracy.
Where do I get the dog?
Wake up, dad!
Time by two seconds.
Daily machine.
Oh my god, it's gonna start breaking down.
Earn 10% more from each passenger you process.
Earn 30% more from...
I'm gonna fucking earn more money.
What?
Uh...
Earn 30% more?
Fuck, yeah.
Sign me up.
Uh...
Let's see.
I feel like there's no reason for me to make a purchase.
Waste my money on that.
All right, my water bill.
Thank God I saved enough money for my water bill.
All right.
Next customer.
Don't forget.
Oh, he had my retirement fund.
It's going to be a while, guys.
They need $100,000.
Now we add baggage limit.
Oh, no.
Match the bag type to the right limit on the boarding pass.
Oh, no!
Now we're adding numbers?
Okay.
Oh, check the tag.
Alright, it's a carry-on bag.
So you'll use the carry-on 8KG.
Open the boarding pass and find it.
Okay.
That's the number that matters.
Put the bag on the scale.
Oh, my god.
Numbers, numbers.
Oh, Dustin, cute.
Hmm, I hope this doesn't break the limit.
Sir, why would you need two tonsons cubes?
Overland, print an overweight limit tag.
Give the ticket to the passenger.
Alright.
It's over the limit.
You gotta pay $40, guys.
I'm gonna put the fucking sticker.
Like...
They're like...
I'm gonna put...
Where do I put the sticker?
Um, sir, uh...
No, just...
Oh, I just give it to him.
Oh, okay.
Paid.
Continue the inspection.
Yeah!
Then reject them as usual.
This is the carry-on, so give it back.
Alright.
Check the tag.
Check the limit.
Charge the fee.
No payment.
No entry.
Alright.
It says pet cube, dokey.
Why are you judging?
My name is Tyler Bennett.
All right.
Um, well, the name is correct.
Oh, that's cute.
All right.
What is this in here?
Ooh, it's a safe vault.
All right.
What's the limit?
It's a checking back.
8 kg.
Oh, sir, this is a little too heavy.
I think it's because you have a fucking...
God damn safe in here.
Alright, next luggage.
Alright, there's also a check-in bag.
12.3.
Another $45 fee, please.
Thank you.
Headlight and another...
Okay, a lot of Tonson Cube is going crazy right now.
The Tonson Cube market.
Who would have thought?
Hudson Cube.
Oh, I wonder if this is also past the limit.
I'll have another $30.
I swear to God if this is another...
Alright, another safe phone.
Sir, I...
I mean, more money for me, I guess.
More...
Look at Mr. Moneybags over here.
It would be a shame if after all of this you're not allowed
through because you fucked up one thing.
Amsterdam.
transit how old are you 30 all right well everything looks
in order so you get to do your other stuff he can pay so
it's fine they get nervous when they pass through the x-ray
who gets nervous
the rubber duckies oh all right just a lot of rubber duck
you know i'm paid to do my job not to judge Guys, remember,
check-in bag, 8KG, Dora Blade, all right?
I mean, seems fine.
Everything seems fine.
His name is Dora Blade.
He's 34.
Undecided.
And he's going to Delhi.
All right.
All right, here you go.
All right, so.
that pass through real quick and then we'll give you this
all right next passenger please next customer my name is
area morgan while that looks fine that should be a check-in
oh already can tell is that another all right 11 kg i don't
have that cotton then why open the safe then If you don't
have that money Oh what is this What are all these in the
save Huh?
No way I'm not paying that Alright I swear to God If I see a
third save Well if it's too bad Looks like I gotta
confiscate all of these saves Alright oh this is ridiculous
Oh out of all of these That's me rejecting you For three
She's cute She has a pass Ha ha ha All right.
Wait until...
Oh, I can't even keep this.
That's cool.
My three saves.
Too bad I can't call security on here.
Apparently, she can't pay it because all her money is in
those three saves.
All right, what's in here?
Oh, another safe.
What is the safe con?
all right nice all right you're good to go ma'am that's fine
at least see she pays for it i'll make sure
this scan i can't tell
all right thanks for the 60 i gotta make sure that let's see
i'm gonna make sure the names on this is correct too Oh my
god, please.
I'm trying to check the tag.
I don't need to keep looking at the saves.
I know you have a safe.
I want to make sure...
Oh, she's going to Moscow with that money.
I'm not paid enough to ask questions about what she's doing
in Moscow with two fucking giant saves.
It's really dopey.
SafeCon is at Moscow.
Or Ross.
How old are you?
27.
Um...
Alright, everything looks good.
You're good to go, man.
Nothing illegal here.
Alright, next passenger.
What the hell's going on?
It's New York City.
You don't ask questions about New York City, guys.
It's New York, New York.
I need to earn 60% more.
Alright, next day.
Level 12, I think, is when I get the dog.
I'm going to make this quick.
I want to know what the dog does.
Our area Morgan.
Alright, 7KG.
Everything is spelled correctly.
Alright, what's in here?
Another tungsten cube.
Alright, maybe this tungsten cube won't...
Oh, never mind.
Alright, well...
Well, you know the drill.
31.
Just gotta make sure you're not lying about anything else to
me.
Alright, boom.
Not gonna pay the fee.
Get out of my airport.
We have five other airports in New York City.
Surely one of them will let you through.
I'm just returning some overdue books.
How bad are these books that you have to bribe me?
How?
Oh, that's a lot of...
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
hold up, hold up, hold up, and you're going to Moscow, and
wait, wait a minute, okay, $200 to sell on my own country am
i you got it is she a spy all right wait but it is 200 so it
is 200 bro is a kgb what's it it's 200 enough to sell out my
own country i'm i'm wondering all right 200 is 200 Paula
page burn mine okay I almost pressed it I almost went
dyslexic there I'm not dyslexic by the way alright you
touched their belagings yeah let's touch their top secret
belagings alright Paula page burn I do not think this is
much this is needed alright very illegal item pop I was like
how old are you I just gotta make sure.
What is your...
Ah, tourism.
I see.
Tourism.
We're gonna need security here.
My name is Hannah.
I'm Hannah Palmer.
I'm not a traitor to the nation.
But 200 is 200.
Okay, I have a feeling that this is...
9 kg only one pound extra lucky you're lucky today all right
what about this one just in case i just want to see what
your life is like you know all right uh 19 conference sydney
my name is hannah palmer all right everything looks good to
go and you have the right boarding pass so We're good.
Yeah, tourism in Moscow.
I see.
Oh, he's back.
Cameron Blake.
Damn, everybody's going to Moscow for some reason.
Oh, wait, I gotta reject you, but I'm gonna see if there's
like money I can get out of you.
Um.
Well, I gotta reject this now.
Uh, expired boarding pass.
Let's check if you are, what you say who you say you are too
oh wait wait i oh my god i get to whoops
that's not what that's what goodbye spider all right here we
go my bad i'm just trying to see if i can grab get extra
money off of this guy at first says hair gel
all right anyway
Anyway, uh, you're not allowed anyway because you fucked up
your boarding date.
Now I got some extra money out of that.
Nice, perfect inspection, guys.
Still perfect.
Whoops.
Sorry, we, uh, threw away your dog accidentally.
We thought he was an illegal item.
We thought he was a bomb.
Sorry, sir.
Oh, wait.
What happened to him?
Where is he?
First, the morning paper now carries checkpoint regulations.
Read it before the first passenger.
Open it.
Oh, shit.
It's raining acid in London!
Oh, my sir, cancel.
Decline path.
Sorry, sir.
You can't go to London.
It's raining acid there.
You know, just a typical Monday morning.
Okay.
Travel to London is not...
Now restricted.
Anyone flying there must be rejected.
Close the paper.
Open the boarding pass.
All right.
Open the report board.
Newspaper rule violation.
Like I feel like.
Can we just like postpone their trip?
Not reject them outright?
Bam.
Your travel has been rejected.
sucks on you for trying to fly here we don't do reschedules
we don't reschedule anything you just got paid for a new
ticket my name is charlotte mitchell oh she's trying to go
to london sorry charlotte i don't know if you heard but uh
it's raining acid sorry bab I'm so sorry.
It's out of my hands.
It's raining acid.
What can I do?
I can't stop the weather for you, ma'am.
Okay, that has to be a violation.
There's a fucking tungsten cube in there.
I recognize the tungsten cube shaped.
Oh my god, never mind.
Yeah, but you have a gaming...
Okay, you have a gaming laptop?
Excuse me, you're supposed to take that out of the out of
the duffel bag Yeah, what's in here?
All right That's good to go Okay, I feel like everything is
good to go.
She's not going to London at least Layla price 47 Toronto,
all right You're good to go, man.
Next customer.
Oh, I love the streets through so much.
I brought some home.
Custom forums do not have a box for emotional support food.
All right.
Is there going to be grass here again?
Is there melted cheese?
Oh, all right.
Sir, your luggage is fine, but I don't think I'm legally
allowed to let you bring grilled rat to the airport.
I'm sorry.
Also, New York does not sell grilled rats.
Unless I've, unless, unless I've clearly been to the wrong
side of New York City.
Bros.
The survival list.
31.
All right.
Well, everything else is good to go, sir.
rats unfortunately you just haven't been you're right maybe
I just haven't been to the right places in New York City
you're so right my name is my name is Skylar huh well first
off unfortunately you can't go to London today and also
unless your alien technology has allowed you to change
colors, I might not feel, I might not be allowed to let you
win.
There might be a chance where it's the alien, it's the alien
cube.
It's the alien cube.
Nothing else, of course.
It's also we just couldn't come in because London illegal
item and might be a photo miscellaneous.
Smash?
Not too sure about it.
And I see she has the Michael Jackson thingy.
I'll take one Master Splinter straight off the grill.
And I see they give a Super Chat thinking, thank you.
Yeah, I hope that was a perfect inspection.
Yeah, oh, I want to oh, we're two more levels left.
Okay, I need to 25% more.
I got earn more money from my customers.
Bills time.
Oh, shit.
Okay, don't worry.
I can pay all my bills tomorrow.
Alright, let's see.
What if she's trying to stop the acid rain with her alien
artifact?
You're so right.
Wait, there's no news article, so we're fine.
This looks like a very heavy package.
Oh, is that another safe I see?
all right give me that money all right that's fine oh i see
safe con is now in paris see they're hosting another safe
con all right and then just to be sure c230 wait is your
name jason carter my name is jason carter all right that's
good to know i just gotta be sure oh a chanel bad oh and a
wedding ring oh that's a lucky lady right there oh wow we
what a lucky gal it's what and you're only 25 hey how long
you hey if you're ever single i know some dragoons that
might be interested ha ha all right you're free to go sir
Wow, he's out.
I realize I've not been looking at photos.
Thank God I haven't got fucked over from that.
Oh my God, another wedding ring.
Look at how big is this.
Wait, actually, I didn't...
Oh, hey, it's just a watch.
These are some very inefficient packers, I will say.
This is a check-in bag, so it's 4KG.
like like see this is fine this is fine he's he's packed
okay for this one all right these are carry-ons uh there
he's a very oh whoa whoa be a shame if that got confiscated
like how people stop bringing bombs through the uh
Through the metal detector.
Which is nice, you know.
Less stuff for me to do.
23.
Damien Claw.
Uh, Deli.
Alright.
You're good to go, Damien.
You're good to go.
Alright, next passenger.
There's an ancient...
Oh, wait.
That's Laura Craft.
Lauren Craft.
Let's just make the processing fast.
All right.
Okay, but are you over the limit, though?
I mean, she's not over the limit.
I see no problem here.
You're so right, guys.
You know what, girl?
You can, you're free to go.
I wonder if I like Do this and then Because I didn't Do
anything with her stuff So do I keep it?
Oh I kept her belying No!
I forgot At least she can still fly Like I forgot to give it
back to her My bad That's an oopsie from me.
Hey, I get $25, though.
Oh, shit.
I didn't do this one correctly.
God, this, like, makes me so paranoid.
That's got profit, baby.
This fucks with me a lot.
Sydney John 1st reject expired boarding pass just to be sure
what's your name my name is okay N name mismatch also how
old are you 43 alright well everything almost looks good
except for the fact that it's not good
No, I forgot to give her the items back so that I don't even
get the bribe.
No!
That's fine.
At least I can pay my bills.
That's all that matters.
Alright, we're finally getting lost and found soon.
And the dog.
I think the dog, when does the dog unlock?
Oh, I can't tell.
It doesn't tell me my things don't break down yet.
I just want to know when my dog's gonna wake up Okay, I paid
my bills Dream they give us super chat.
Thank you.
I really appreciate that.
Thank you
All right Madra added something new to the desk passion
usually may have things they found in the airport This is
the loss of a found train.
It stays hidden until you need it Right-click to slide it
out.
See the blue tag?
That marks an official lost item.
Put it in the tray.
It's the iPhone.
Alright.
After ship takes store items to lost but found.
The tray only stores them.
You get paid when you hand them in.
Blue tag, tray office.
Oh, man.
It would be a shame if I...
Someone lost this item.
I get paid for every lost item?
That seems...
Oh, he is.
the time traveler oh man you're back bro that's a tungsten
cube i don't even have to look that's a tungsten cube right
there all right do you have any okay well you can't all
right my name is well i gotta reject you because you're not
paying for 18.
all right total mismatch overweight item
fucking get out of here i'm just gonna let all this pass
through at this point just try to see if there's anything
illegal i can oh you're so lucky oh you're so lucky all
right get out of here get your ass out of here uh sorry do
you know where my gate is um i am the tsa uh that's not part
of my job What is this?
3.16.
Oh, that's a lot of...
3.16 pounds for cigarettes?
What the fuck is going on?
How heavy are these cigarettes?
Okay.
Name, sir?
Jamie's smoke.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, I should have known.
Shit.
I should have known.
Okay.
Well, everything else looks in order, so...
Alright.
Oh.
What's that?
Oh!
Oh, okay.
She's just a little... Oh!
Okay.
Oh!
That... That looks very gun-shaped.
Oh, the Tokyo!
Oh, okay.
Alright.
That... That is indeed a gun.
That...
That's a gun.
Alright, Leo Bennett.
Alright, well.
And this too.
I think that might be a gun.
Alright, I feel like I might have to look through all your
bags just in case.
Okay, but is it...
Alright, 2KG.
Oh, and a... Okay, alright.
Oh, but you have a really nice keyboard.
And Happy Souls 2?
I mean, here's that, and is this over the weight limit?
You're fine?
Oh, what a wild wedding, that's for sure.
That's a wild wedding.
Hey, look.
It's got to do some Rubik's Cube, I guess.
Where's my board?
His name is Leo Bennett.
He's 35.
Um, let's see.
Everything.
else seems to be in order other than the legal item other
than the several legal items you seem to be seem to have
your things in order anyway security
yeah just a little grenade in the hala kitty tote bag you
know just business okay one carry on 2.40 all right have
these solos oh that's a very popular game you're fine ma'am
um there's no acid rains going anywhere Bella Scott how old
are you 50 uh where are you traveling to Sydney all right ma
'am have a nice flight have a safe flight ma'am hope you
enjoy your trip and Australia.
It's nice that only four people, we were only allowed four
people a day to fly.
Oh, hey, lost item.
You know.
Thank God.
This airport, maybe that's why we don't have a lot of
funding.
We only allow four people to fly each day.
That's all we can take, guys.
Oh, my God.
Now, imagine date night with partner.
How partner while working at the TSA?
I have time for that.
Click to continue.
Oh, whoa.
Oh, my God.
Now it's a visual novel.
Oh, he looks so cool.
Oh, top secret.
There's a story.
So remember that little lost item tree?
Turns out it can't.
lost from stolen.
See what I left on your desk?
No blue tag.
Still mine.
The tray won't care.
Open it.
Now stash my item.
Okay.
Close it before someone walks in.
The tray has the goods.
It doesn't.
Leon?
The game has lore?
Bring it to me after work.
I'll handle the rest.
What?
Wait.
I can start stealing now.
Oh my god, it's my dream come true.
It's what I've been working towards all this time.
Oh, finally.
Oh my god.
The pickle of jars.
Finally.
I've been waiting for this moment.
Oh, and he doesn't want...
Oh, it's Christmas.
It's Mickey Christmas.
I get to reject you anyway.
Alright, how old are you?
Twenty-three.
You didn't want to pay the pass.
You want to pay the five for the troll-toler.
Finally.
I've been working for the...
this moment my name is Chloe Foster or KG okay but what the
fuck is that top secret shit that he's doing though all
right what's in here I whoa let's see you all right let's
see hey it works
Oh my god, is that dog shirt?
Is that?
The donkey.
It's what I know if it works.
It.
Oh, that seems like a lot.
Okay, no, apparently those are all lightweight items.
And you're fine here, ma'am.
Even though there's no evidence that you have a bomb, I'm
just gonna...
Ooh.
Wait.
Hey.
Whoa.
All right.
We're going to have to cost illegal item found.
Hit the loss and save ball.
Loads up.
All right.
What's this?
I have a first.
You don't need to check my bag, right?
Oh, I'm deaf.
Oh, I'm looking.
Oh, I'm looking for you to check my bag.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, what's in it?
Oh, oh, oh, it's just, uh, it's just, is this John, Jamie
smoke?
Oh, I found your brother earlier.
Don't worry, at least your bag is like in, okay.
Oh, man, he got me so excited for a moment.
Jamie smoke, 25.
I feel like they stopped caring about the photo.
All right, you're approved.
Oh, oh, sorry, I got a little too excited.
there can i confiscate your passport imagine if i could
confiscate his passport
um what's this empty aquarium all right what do you have in
here what's that that looks illegal that's radium all right
you know at least he like oh also he does definitely okay
you know at least he like gave me the last item you know
before he might be trying to the airport but at least he
like uh oh yeah all right very bad spy not very good at his
job all right and also overweight like i don't even i don't
have the money you're a spy oh there are so many things
wrong here all right illegal item overweight fee refused
photo mismatch.
Oh, shit.
What's... All right.
What was that?
Another fireworks.
Here you go.
Um, oh, and a pregnancy test.
Oh, did you just throw a bomb in there?
I didn't say, and a pregnancy?
You're pregnant?
Congratulations.
Um, are you at least your age?
28.
You know, Calvin.
He's his name.
So, like, that's fine.
Anyway, security.
I was like, oh, my God, and you're...
Oh, oh.
Wait.
Expired.
Oh, I didn't even check the boarding pass.
Wait.
Wait, I don't get...
Oh, my God.
I don't...
I don't get punished for it.
Wait.
minute oh wait a minute whoa oh but I get five dollars I
wait hey hey buddy I got you a watch I got you
oh wait what's the point what's the point wait a minute
what's the point wait a minute what's okay wait oh you're
not bringing anything what are you doing here okay multiple
sources report dangerous arrest passengers with a surname
Bennett like oh and they're not gonna fucking change their
name what kind of fucking criminal are you what's the point
what's oh I didn't see if the the boarding pass was Correct.
Brother, let me slip this time.
I got you.
You know what?
We'll get you more money for me.
Oh, it's Jamie Smoke again.
It is 200 dots.
You know what?
I can make it more money by doing this.
I think I can make more money doing that.
Alright, what is your name?
Jamie Smoke.
How old are you, 31?
Alright.
Boop.
Here we go.
Where do I get my dog?
Wait, Eliza.
You bro.
Nobody's bringing anything anymore.
Oh, Eliza.
Eliza.
Eliza, Eliza.
I mean, damn, that plastic.
That hair dye goes wild, though.
Uh.
I will say that hair dye wig, that's a real glow-up.
Oh, I found this at an airport.
Oh, a real lost and found him.
Nobody's bringing anything anymore.
I think they realized.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Bennett.
Anyone with the name Bennett?
You're a suspect who cried.
It doesn't matter what.
It doesn't matter if Bennett's a common name.
They heard the rumors.
I can't believe it.
Nobody brought me money.
Oh, hey, another last item.
Alright.
Hey, sir.
I got you some more.
Oh, yeah, this is much more.
Whoa, yeah.
When do I get my dog?
Wait, what is he doing here?
Oh, it's just like, hey, are you sure you got me all the
goods?
It's like, I'm sure, bro.
I'm sure I got you everything I can.
Oh, dog time?
Valuable things keep disappearing.
So management installed a cam.
No!
Red light on means it's watching the desk if it sees you.
Oh, it's...
Don't worry.
It's time.
We're five.
The five comes straight out of your pocket.
This item still blocks me.
No blue tag.
Open the tray and put it inside.
Is this bait?
Go on.
This is bait, isn't it?
This is a test.
Gus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's okay, guys.
It's okay.
We don't have enough funding to keep the camera on all the
time.
But Gus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday, Gus.
you happy birthday to you happy birthday dear guys happy
birthday to you yeah happy birthday guys happy birthday also
this was set up i only 12 did oh thank god okay it gave me
back my okay good okay i was gonna say um blue tag means
like no tag means passenger property close the trip
passengers may miss that the camera won't all right all
right that's all right see that was a real last item all
right Olivia what's the point what's the point if I can't
steal no more this is a check-in all right you're good this
bag is good to go all right this bag is good to not have to
actually do my job
doesn't feel the same anymore it does not feel the same all
right good to go i guess the rush is gone now oh shit walter
crystal and the it's just a highly specialized cure for my
son And look, um, oh, it has a raincoat.
Yeah, it's a cure.
His son has cancer, guys.
Wait, is it over the weight limit, though?
Oh, you're five.
Guys, his son has cancer.
Do you really want his son to die?
When will the camera turn off?
Area Dawson.
Uh, 29.
Everything looks good to go.
How am I supposed to- How would I know the camera's- Oh,
does that mean it's off?
Wait.
When he's blinking, is it off when he's looking at me?
I'm gonna test it out.
Okay.
No!
I was just testing the theory out.
Oh, my $150.
It's not.
Line, it wasn't off, guys.
It wasn't off.
I don't know how...
I can't tell when it...
Oh, 78?
Alright, let's hope you there's...
Okay, there is illegal.
Okay, But is it past the wait?
Alright, so that's an illegal item.
Oh, that's another illegal item.
I mean, everything.
Oh, but she got a selfie stick, though.
Um, I do think you might be...
Yep, I was going to say.
Yep, that seems right.
Illegal item.
everything else seems good to go oh and expired boarding
pass yeah so I'm just gonna have to call security will I
confiscate this Chloe Bennett oh and your name is Bennett
too
when does the dog get here I'm still waiting on the dog
right now found this I can't even steal anymore.
I can't even steal.
I've lost the passion.
I...
Alright.
You're 5.
Oh, whoa.
Baby diaper.
Like, the passion's gone.
Madison Pierce.
Yeah.
All right, you're good to go.
The adrenaline's gone.
I know, right?
All right, perfect, right.
Perfect, perfect.
God, I'm just too good at my job.
You know, when you're so good at your job, everything just
becomes so mundane now.
Like, there's no point.
There's no more, no thrill of it anymore.
Like, it's just, it's just all just, you're just going
through the system right now.
now.
Just going through the grind.
Yeah, why steal when there's no... Oh, shit.
Another lost item.
I don't get why the guy would uh... wouldn't want to buy the
aquarium from me.
It seems like a good deal.
Is the dog here now?
Is the dog here?
Well, that's a nasty little camera.
Your thing government tech is built by the lowest building.
I let you left you away and click the camera
What I do I hack a camera but I don't have a dog
Lean you only get a few hacks each day save them for
something worth stealing for all right
My god I'm guys I'm doing wires I Can't beat an imposter
guys I'm doing why where's my dog where the fuck's my dog
like i'm doing wires and i don't have my dog
all right age and name all right oh wait no name is fine
photo
oh whoa okay let's see and then and oh oh and you can't pay
okay all right that's that's with me that's good with me let
me wait let me get all of this in first oh and you have a
tungsten cube i i recognize a tungsten tube cube when i see
one i okay it's hacking time
that tungsten cube's gonna go so hard not gonna lie and i
found an illegal item Let's see.
What else?
Name is Matt.
Wait, is your name?
Mia Collins?
Yeah.
Okay.
Alright.
Security!
I found something worth stealing for.
It's Hudson Cube is gonna go so high.
I am donating these eventually.
Please focus on the word eventually.
Alright, what is this?
What the fuck?
Oh, shit oh oh oh and a thousand whoa wait is it over wait
let me put everything up back let me uh no let me put
everything back and then oh you're so lucky oh whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa calm down calm down calm down here don't
worry sir i'll make sure you get to where you need to go.
Okay, that at least is correct.
You got one thing correct.
Illegal item.
Age mismatch.
Everything else is fine.
But, I will say...
Alright, 1C.
E now.
Oops.
Wait, I can't just take a thousand dollars?
Where does a thousand dollars come from?
Um, just some illegal stuff going on here.
Just an illegal man.
Oh, what the fuck is going on?
Oh, that's my money?
deposit.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my God, I could have gotten it.
Oh, I could have had another alien artifact as well.
Surely it's not that expensive, right?
Alright, let's see.
How are you?
Alright, at least that's alright.
Just has an illegal thing.
Oh, nine.
Oh, and also, thanks.
But also, it's still illegal but thanks for the 20 dollars i
i really appreciate that oh
there you go this always fucks me up anyway security she
obviously has a tan yeah yeah a tan all right oh do i have
anything illegal on you sir god you're just rolling in oh
Aw, come on, I already used my camera!
How is I supposed to know everybody's gonna start running in
here and fucking bring shit?
Like, come on!
Everyone's going fucking wild today.
Wait, confiscate your illegal item.
Okay.
Come on!
It's not fair!
That fucking carry a gold bomb.
Let's just give me all the illegal stuff now.
A cold and get mad.
What a shame.
Wait, this is more than four.
I'm pretty sure.
Oh my god.
The first person that's not bringing luggage.
Absolutely wild.
My name is Audrey45.
Alright.
the first real passenger all right perfect perfect correct
oh i guys i don't see color
sorry i don't pay attention to somebody's skin tone when i'm
doing it when i'm when i'm doing the tsa stuff
Oh, $86, $30, $2, $1, $73.
Oh, $60, $166.
Let's let go.
All right, let's see.
That was a lot of money.
Oh, another missing item.
Oh, my God.
Things are getting more expensive.
My rent is going up.
Do I get my dog now?
Still no dog?
When does the dog come?
I swear to God.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry, sir.
I just wanted to radiate your legs a little bit.
Oh, that's a safe right there.
Oh, that's a lake.
Alright, let's see.
Oh.
Oh, that's my total money that I could just flung around.
Oh, okay.
All right, let's just see what you have.
380.
Is that your...
Okay.
Well, you're not allowed to bring exotic wine bottles, so...
All right, what's this?
All right, that's fine.
Oh, oh, I'm pretty sure it's not over the weight limit.
be fine at least hmm you know what you know what Xavier I'm
feeling generous that's not not enough illegal items for me
unless it's an illegal item I'm not gonna hack the cameras
these are lucky they mr.
Xavier stone all right you're good to go next person please
you miss Harper 18 January 17 All right, your one bag.
Oh, that's another SafeCon?
All right.
Good to go, ma'am.
Okay.
Harper, Hunter, 18.
All right.
Everything's good to go.
Enjoy your trip to SafeCon.
Damn.
Ever since...
Oh, Logan, press.
It's like when Saudi Arabia bought uh oh whoa mysterious
powder when they bought evil and then we have 20 evils now i
guess like i guess they went into the safe business guys and
now we have 20 safe cons oh is that chicken bag oh wait no
that yeah that's the chicken bag yeah
590 you're good to go sir except for this mysterious powder
which means you're not good to go sir Illegal item found.
What's your name?
How old are you?
Yeah, I thought so.
I'm so good at this now.
I'm impressed.
Oop.
Nice $30.
That's his oregano.
I shared that fresh organ.
Oh!
Oh, fresh Oregon, you say.
Oh, that is definitely not fresh.
Oh, I got a little too excited.
Oh,
what's the point?
Dr. Henry Kane.
Oh, wait, that's Hannibal Lecter.
That might have been.
Whoops.
All right.
I mean, we're still...
Guys, don't worry.
I've detained a cannibal.
I just realized that's Hannibal Lecter.
Do not worry.
I am a hero today.
I have detained a criminal.
Uh, poop.
Dr. Harriet Canine.
There we go.
Our last customer.
My name is Stella Stone.
Oh, there's that in there.
Oh, that's acid.
All right.
You know what that means, guys?
But first up, will she pay for her tons...
Oh, yeah, that's a...
Will she pay for a ton...
Oh, yeah.
Will she pay for a tons and cube?
Oh, of course you wouldn't, ma'am.
Of course she would.
You never do.
Will she pay for other tons and cube?
Will she pay for her safe as well?
Oh, no?
Oh, man.
And what is the...
this.
Oh, and her rubber duckies?
Wow, it would be a shame if something happens to the camera.
Would be quite a shame.
Excuse me?
What?
How the fuck am I supposed to hack this?
Oh.
Oh, I didn't hack properly.
Okay, that's fine.
Is that everything?
There we go.
Oh, no!
No!
All the money I just stole again!
I got so excited.
All the money I stole.
God, just like that.
The last millisecond.
Perfect, perfect, perfect, perfect.
A flawless day.
All right, let's go to Austin, Fallon.
Look at my dog now.
Is my doggo gonna be here?
Alright, it's better to make up $150.
This did not make up $150.
Oh, oh, oh, I made profit.
Doesn't matter.
I profited.
My Tunson Cube.
Thank God for the Tunson Cube coming in clutch.
Worth it.
Is the dog over here?
New toy for you.
We've had too far too...
Hmm.
This is a swap test.
pick up the device from the station I'm picking it up it's
where do I I've picked it up what do you want oh oh oh oh my
god it's a lot more convoluted than I thought it's clear All
right, your left hand, sir.
Gotta see if you were jorking it with those chemicals.
There.
Alarm means narcotics.
Smart carrying drugs on the report board.
Then call security.
Clear as all to keep the inspector moving.
All right.
We're going to have to test that out.
Come on.
Give me your hands.
Were you caught jorking it?
Wow, wow, wow, whoa, whoa, whoa, but also what's in your
items?
Let me double check.
All right.
Let me double check if there's anything valuable.
Carrying drugs.
Where's the drugs?
It says you were carrying drugs, sir.
And I would like to know where are these drugs?
I can confiscate them.
I feel like I'm being lied to.
Sir?
Where are you keeping the goods?
Do I call security?
I don't remember I'm supposed to call security.
I...
Ma'am, you told me that if there's an alarm, I got it.
Do I call security?
I'm gonna call security You was caught jorking it, ma'am I'm
so sad I'm about to become a business I'm gonna let me
through and we both eat well Alright Someone's gonna get
through but it's not gonna be you How many squids are Whoa,
alright Alright, I need to know how Oh my gosh, and there's
an unknown liquid Alright, 1C nine one c all right i'll grab
that oh no i touched your belongings well it's only me let
me see if you have drugs too
all right clear oh seems like everything else is fine sally
calamari are you 30?
oh you look good for 30.
anyway oh yeah you're fine Seems your bag is just super
light.
You have very, very light baggage.
Alright, found this at the air.
What the fuck is that?
Is that a coffee brewing machine?
Oh, Ethan.
Damn.
Is that Tonson Cube?
I don't know.
It's just...
But is he going to Australia?
Yeah, I'm sorry.
I know...
Look, I know Australia.
Australia is scary, but, like, sorry, I can't let you bring
that spray.
Uh, it's definitely not a tungsten cube.
What is that?
Is that hand cream?
Sorry, I can make a bomb with that.
I can't let you do that.
Alright.
Yeah, I don't blame him.
Oh, whoops.
I get this instead of a dog.
That's just gonna sleep forever.
You'll sleep on the job.
Go to a mismatch.
25 oh and also boarding pass
it's like you don't care about this travel alright well
she's the last girl so I might as well steal whatever is in
here oh there's three baggages I mean borrow I mean lost I
might as well make sure that all the items go to their rifle
owners you know just trying to make sure all the items go to
their rightful owners it's in here oh oh oh all right uh our
area let me double check everything if everything is in
order with you uh what is your name ariad Dawson how old are
you 20 um and looks like everything is in order let me uh
write this down real quick for you.
Alright, everything looks like it's in order.
And I hope you have a...
Wait.
Give me a sec.
Oh!
I hope you have a safe flight!
Enjoy your trip!
My name is Victoria Harper.
Alright, Victoria, what do you have here?
Ooh, that looks like an elite.
That looks like a $50 payout.
That's what it looks like.
Oh, all right.
Just to be sure.
Because you are.
I don't know.
I feel like.
Maybe.
Just.
Just to be sure.
Oh, you're cleared.
That's good to know.
At least you wash your hands.
You know.
All right.
Let me...
Let me a sec.
Let me position everything correctly.
And then also...
Sorry.
The machine's not working today very well.
So give me a sec while I fix the machine real quick.
Anyway.
Looks like everything is not in order, unfortunately, ma'am.
Because you are carrying it.
legal substance um so i gotta boop carry illegal goodbye
goodbye ma'am perfect inspection perfect inspection perfect
ha perfect look at that wowie s performance too i'm so good
at my job guys i'm just so good at what i do wait wait oh
wait no i don't want to purchase it
four dollars 25 nine don't worry don't worry the big ticket
item is coming don't worry oh or the 33 oh the squids
i told you i told you the big ticket item and the salt salt
shaker is bonus the salt
No, it's like, look, look, um, I think like the lost and
found must have misplaced it.
I know for sure I bagged it.
You know I bagged the illegal substances, guys.
You know I do my job every day, day in, day out.
I am a model employee.
I swear if there's no dog here, I swear if there's no dog
here, I'm out.
How much do I need to pay off?
A hundred grand?
Well, I guess I'm never going to retire.
right click this all right guys i'm calling it here i guess
dad never woke up i'll never got the dog
i never got the dog why did it tempt me with the dog food if
the dog was never gonna show up that's it I have not been
paid for the last eight months working here I quit my dog
never even woke up he slept for the entire job no dog zero
out of ten and for some reason after dokeybird quit work
quit work at the TSA and items we're becoming less stolen
stolen items dropped down exponentially from the airport huh
obviously there's a correlation does not equal causation
guys people's Apple watches started appearing again anyway
guys I'm Akala here today we do have a second stream later
on with Armacord we're trying to get the first ending today
but like I said I'm gonna have a very very busy day today
I'll be heading out right now to do some last-minute
shopping for some stuff before my vacation.
Yeah, lowest complete levels of complaint in eight months.
It's very surprising.
Hey, guys.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Yeah, but move around and get that blood flow.
You stand for me.
Head to bed, guys.
You deserve it.
Like I said, there might be, I might, if I'm late for armor
core, I will let you guys know in advance, most likely.
be like 30 minutes later or something just because i need to
like get you know have the drive back home and everything so
i'll keep you guys updated also before i go before i go i
want to show a little bit um we do have uh we do i'm gonna
try to like extend uh the pre-orders for the ep merch for
another week or so because i realized i uh i realized i uh
forgot to oh i can oh yeah never mind i uh ep merch will
pre-orders will be out extended for another week just
because i forgot to tweet about it i realized because of
everything going on and also i'll be on vacation so i won't
be able to chill as much when i'm on vacation so ep merch
pre-orders extended for another week so please make sure to
pre-order the ep merch i really appreciate all the support
guys uh for the for the birthday merch drop so yeah make
sure to check it out buy my merch get the dokey boxers I'll
see you guys later today.
Bye, everybody.
Bye.